L’interview de Léna
pour Brut.
Ça va être exceptionnel.
- Salut, Léna !
- Bonjour Rémy,
bonjour Brut.
- Comment ça va ?
- Ça va très bien. Et vous ?
- Ça va.
Comme un lundi matin,
c’est un peu dur,
mais ça va...
- J’adore le lundi matin.
- Ah ouais ?
- J’adore le lundi,
j’adore le lundi
parce que tout le monde déteste le lundi.
Du coup, j’ai envie
de lui donner du love.
C’est comme le jaune.
C’est devenu
ma couleur préférée
parce que personne...
Ils étaient en mode :
“Ouais, moi, j’aime
le rouge, j’aime le bleu.”
Je suis en mode “non” :
aimons le jaune
et aimons le lundi.
- On se met un petit peu
à contre-courant parfois.
- C’est ça !
- Bon, on va essayer
de se mettre bien,
tout doucement,
parce que l’interview,
on est partis pour
à peu près 1 heure
de conversation.
- Mais, 1 heure,
tu penses que...
Je vais faire chier les gens, moi, je pense.
- Je pense pas,
je pense pas.
Au contraire,
il y a tellement
de choses à évoquer.
- Une heure de moi.
Je suis navrée
pour tous ceux
qui vont regarder
cette vidéo.
Mais merci d’être là.
- On a tout là,
donc il y a plein de choses.
Et l’idée,
c’est d’y aller en douceur,
avec des
questions un peu...
ce qu’on appelle
ping-pong.
- Ping-pong !
- Voilà.
Donc c’est... Voilà,
je t’envoie la balle,
tu me la renvoies, voilà,
il manque juste
la table entre nous deux.
Vu la distance,
on pourrait la mettre.
- Écoute, j’ai fait ping-pong
au bac de sport, donc...
Cuisine-moi.
- Moi, je suis mal barré, donc on va éviter,
mais du coup, voilà,
petite première question :
c’est quoi, un peu,
ton mood du moment ?
- Mon mood du moment ?
Encore un peu en gueule de bois du nouvel an,
mélangé à
beaucoup d’ambition
et d’envie
pour cette année,
mélangé à un relâchement de pression,
parce que
c’est ma spécialité,
c’est de me mettre constamment la pression.
Et cette année,
j’ai décidé de chill.
- La musique
que tu écoutes
le plus en ce moment ?
- Oh, moi, tu sais,
je suis une vieille dame,
j’écoute Marvin Gaye,
je sais pas ce qui se passe
dans les Spotify
du moment, mais...
j’ai une playlist, j’en ai
un peu honte parfois.
- Ta plus grande qualité ?
- Je crois que je suis une personne sympatoche,
gentille, organisée.
Allez, j’en fais plein.
- Le plus grand défaut ?
Euh... Très dissipée,
gros manque
de concentration,
complètement anxieuse,
constamment
se met la pression,
peut créer un trou noir
et embarquer
tous ses potes avec.
Mais...
toujours avec le sourire.
- Toujours avec le sourire,
mais la plus grande peur dans ta vie ?
- Plus grande peur ?
Elle est horrible,
mais c’est de...
perdre un proche.
Enfin, je pense que c’est
celle de tout le monde.
Après, il y a
les serpents, mais...
- Ton plus grand regret ?
- Oh, plus grand regret ?
Tu sais quoi ?
On aime bien dire :
non, j’ai pas
de regrets, et tout, mais...
il y a des fois
où, le matin, je me réveille
et je regrette un peu de...
des shots de tequila.
Donc là, c’est ceux du nouvel an que je regrette !
- Le maximum
de temps que tu as pu
déconnecter
des réseaux sociaux ?
Maximum de temps :
ben, quand ma mère
me confisquait
mon téléphone
quand j’avais des mauvaises notes,
et sinon, plus récemment, pendant douze jours,
quand je suis partie
faire le Kilimandjaro
avec mon chéri.
Tu peux avoir ton téléphone, il est là,
mais tu n’as absolument aucune barre de réseau
ni quoi que ce soit.
Et il fait tellement froid que le téléphone s’éteint.
Tu connais, l’iPhone,
quand il fait
genre trois degrés,
il commence à s’éteindre.
Bah là, c’était ça,
donc douze jours.
- Le partenariat le plus étrange que tu as refusé ?
- Ouf, il y en a pas mal.
Je pense que
chaque influenceur
pourrait écrire un bouquin
sur les demandes cheloues.
J’ai eu beaucoup
de choses
concernant la politique,
ce avec quoi j’étais
pas du tout à l’aise,
et je trouve que c’est assez chelou parce que...
parce qu’on sait
comment ça fonctionne
et on essaie un peu
de ramener les gens,
je trouve que
c’est très, très malsain,
surtout les jeunes,
quand on sait qu’ils ont pas encore eu le temps
vraiment de se créer
une conscience politique
d’eux-mêmes,
et avant même
qu’ils creusent
de leur côté,
de leur ramener des informations politiques,
je trouve que
c’est assez malsain.
Donc je le rentrerais
dans la catégorie chelou.
Puis après, évidemment, on a tous les types
de produits dropshipping,
produits qui n’arriveront jamais, arnaques,
produits dangereux,
tabac, alcool
et tutti quanti.
- Des politiques
qui t’ont approchée,
ça me rend curieux,
c’est quels partis ?
- Tous.
- Tous ?
- Ouais.
- Du coup,
ils ont essayé quoi ?
- Ouais, c’est...
Mais c’est juste
pour se rendre,
aussi peut-être un peu plus cool et jeunes,
ce que je comprends,
ce qui est une bonne idée
quand tu te mets
de leur côté,
je trouve que
c’est une bonne idée.
Mais quand nous, on est de notre côté, en fait,
à partir du moment
où tu te rends compte
que c’est des vraies personnes qui te suivent
et que c’est pas juste des chiffres, c’est des gens,
humains,
avec une conscience,
avec leur façon
de penser, etc.,
et je trouve que
c’est assez dangereux
de les ramener vers
des partis politiques,
surtout quand c’est pas ceux auxquels toi tu...
que tu soutiens, quoi.
Donc il y a
une différence entre
partager ses valeurs
et rameuter politiquement
et un petit peu manipuler.
- Donc toi, tu ne vas
jamais aller vers ça ?
- Non, je pense pas.
Je te dis ça aujourd’hui.
Peut-être que j’aurai
envie de devenir
maire de Paris
un jour, donc...
- Ça a l’air compliqué comme job quand même,
c’est un guêpier, je crois.
- C’est la blague
entre mes potes,
mais c’est que
j’aime tellement Paris,
on dirait vraiment
que je suis payée
par la Ville de Paris
pour en faire la promotion,
mais je suis vraiment
la Emily in Paris,
je suis en mode...
Vive la ville, quoi.
- Il n’y a pas longtemps, t’as sorti une vidéo,
justement,
sur Emily in Paris,
est-ce qu’un jour
on peut te voir dedans ?
- C’est pas prévu.
Après, moi,
j’adore les exercices
un peu nouveaux,
et la série me fait...
me fait sourire, je trouve ça attendrissant
de voir comment ils imaginent les Français,
Paris, et ils mettent
en lumière la ville,
tu vois, donc ça reste...
Et puis,
franchement, merde,
c’est quand même un peu drôle, Emily in Paris.
- Donc pourquoi pas.
- Pourquoi pas !
- Mais il n’y a pas de concret pour l’instant.
- Non, non.
- Ton artiste favori ?
- Rihanna dans
l’entièreté de sa carrière.
- Une source d’inspiration au quotidien ?
- Seb, mon copain.
- La vidéo sur
ta chaîne YouTube
dont tu es la plus fière ?
- Écoute, je suis fière des premiers vlogs d’août,
tu vois, c’est
des vidéos que je fais
tous les mois d’août.
Je fais un concept qui s’appelle les vlogs d’août
et c’est vraiment
très simple,
c’est des vlogs en août
et c’est pas la vidéo…
C’est pas les vidéos
les plus produites,
c’est pas les vidéos
les plus travaillées,
parce que comme
c’est du daily vlog,
donc tu n’as que quelques heures pour le monter,
c’est pas
la meilleure qualité,
mais les premiers
vlogs d’août,
ce que je trouve
hyper mignon,
c’est qu’il y avait
300 personnes
qui les regardaient et je continuais de les poster,
et je suis assez fière de ça, de ne pas avoir attendu
que des gens
regardent mes vidéos
pour faire des vidéos.
- Justement, c’est : jusqu’à quand tu comptes faire
des vlogs d’août ?
Toute ta vie ?
- Je pense que
si un jour je dis
“j’arrête les vlogs d’août”,
les gens vont
venir chez moi
et m’arracher
ma perruque.
Donc...
Non, je sais pas.
Je les ferai jusqu’à
ce que je trouve
que ça fasse sens.
Et après, c’est comme
une bonne série, tu vois,
Friends, ils auraient
pu continuer
encore des années,
moi, j’aurais été là pour regarder, mais des fois,
il y a des choses qui
sont vraiment très cool
et qui appartiennent
à un temps.
Et après, ça fait sens
de fermer le chapitre.
Mais ça pourrait
être cette année,
ça pourrait être
dans cinq ans, je sais pas.
J’ai pas de
planning, en tout cas.
- Est-ce qu’il y a une vidéo que tu regarderais
aujourd’hui en 2023
sur ta chaîne où tu dirais
“ouh là, ça, j’aurais
pas dû la poster”
ou tu dis “bon, celle-là me gêne un petit peu” ?
- Bah, les premières
vont me gêner de...
de trucs idiots, quoi, parce que j’étais très, très timide,
beaucoup moins
à l’aise face à la caméra,
et puis je sens...
En fait, je les regarde
et je me rappelle imaginer
ce que mes copains
et ce que les gens
à l’école allaient dire.
Du coup, j’étais
très, très, très timide
et je m’étais mise un peu dans une petite boîte
dans ces toutes premières vidéos, mais...
je les ai laissées
sur la chaîne YouTube
parce qu’elles font
partie d’une évolution,
elles font partie
d’un truc, quoi,
donc ce serait regrettable de les regretter.
- Un rêve pour 2023 ?
- Être en bonne
santé physique
et santé mentale.
- On en parlera pas mal dans l’interview.
Où tu te vois
dans dix ans ?
- J’espère dans
une grande maison
avec une chambre
pour Marcus, Solène,
mes parents...
et un chien.
Si dans dix ans,
je n’ai pas un chien,
c’est que j’ai raté un truc.
- Il y a le déménagement
en cours, j’ai vu, là.
- Ah ouais, m’en parle pas.
Ouais, ouais,
je me suis fait gentiment
dégager
de mon appartement.
Les propriétaires
veulent le récupérer
et du coup, ils m’ont dit :
“Il faut que tu le quittes.”
Je n’étais pas prête à déménager, mais ça y est.
- Du coup, là, début 2023, c’est les cartons.
- Ah ouais,
je suis en plein cartons, là,
je vous quitte, après, je vais aller faire des cartons.
- Ben bon courage,
mais on a besoin de
toi encore un petit peu.
Si tu devais décrire Léna Situations en trois mots,
ce seraient lesquels ?
- Créatrice.
- Créatrice. De.
- Créatrice. De. Contenu.
Facile.
- Bien joué !
Bien joué, c’est pas mal.
Là, il y a 2023
et il y a un terme
que j’ai vu souvent
à la fois dans ton podcast
et encore même hier
dans ta story,
c’est le terme de l’anxiété.
- Ouais.
- C’est un peu
ton mood du moment ?
- Oh, c’est mon mood
de ma vie depuis...
C’est un sujet
qui est assez difficile
de mettre
des mots dessus,
étant donné
que dans ta tête,
c’est assez clair,
mais dès qu’il faut passer le trajet de ce qui se passe
entre ta tête
et le dire à voix haute,
il y a toujours
une sorte de blocage
et les mots se mélangent parce qu’en réalité,
c’est un concept qui est quand même assez flou
et d’autant plus pour
les personnes anxieuses,
je pense, entre nous,
on se comprend,
où des fois tu arrives pas
à exprimer ce qui se passe
dans ton cerveau
et t’arrives pas
à comprendre
pourquoi, en fait,
pourquoi ton cerveau
est mal branché,
pourquoi tout le monde arrive à avancer et toi,
d’un coup, tu dois
te mettre sur pause
pour repenser à toute
ta vie de ces quinze
dernières années alors que tout allait plutôt bien.
- Et c’est quoi ?
C’est la crainte de
ne pas être à la hauteur ?
C’est quoi ?
C’est la confiance en soi ?
- Je pense que c’est même plus profond que ça.
C’est pas forcément
lié au travail,
c’est pas forcément
lié à ma situation,
lié à quoi que ce soit,
c’est des choses
qui m’arrivaient
déjà un peu
avec l’école, en fait,
je m’en rends compte.
Après, ça fait un grand boum quand évidemment
ta vie est exposée.
Mais à la fin de la journée, c’est mon choix.
Si j’ai envie d’arrêter d’exposer ma vie,
je peux très bien le faire...
Bon, je me ferais chier,
quand même.
Mais, tu sais, c’est des choses que tu contrôles.
Je contrôle mon contenu,
je contrôle ce que
je poste sur les réseaux,
mais parfois,
je ne contrôle
pas forcément comment ma tête va assimiler
toutes les informations.
- Est-ce que tu contrôles la petite voix dans ta tête ?
Parce que tu nous
en parles souvent.
Justement,
est-ce que c’est quelque chose d’incontrôlé ?
- Mais attendez,
vous savez que tout
le monde n’a pas
la petite voix
dans sa tête ?
J’en parlais avec
une amie et je disais :
“Mais tu vois,
moi, c’est la voix,
elle me l’a dit, il fallait que... qu’on y aille, quoi.”
Elle dit :
“Mais quelle voix ?”
Et en fait,
cette petite voix...
Je suis pas folle,
vous aussi, vous avez une petite voix dans votre tête
qui vous parle ?
Ah ouais, moi,
elle est super présente
et c’est ma cops, quoi.
C’est une copine.
Alors, des fois,
elle est pas très cool,
mais cette petite voix dans ma tête,
je sais pas,
elle est là au quotidien
et on guide un peu
nos journées comme ça.
Et la petite voix
dans ma tête
peut être ma plus grande cheerleader,
mais elle peut être aussi ma plus grande hater.
- Hater, même,
parfois, c’est-à-dire...
Ta petite voix, parfois,
elle te parle mal.
- C’est surtout
elle qui me parle mal !
- Qui te chamboule
un petit peu.
- Oui, c’est surtout
que je laisse
beaucoup de place...
Je me rends compte
que j’intellectualise
beaucoup d’événements qui sont assez banals
et qui n’ont pas besoin
d’être autant intellectualisés,
qui ont pas besoin d’être autant remis en question,
réfléchis.
Et au final, c’est ça, peut-être, parfois,
qui pose souci.
- Alors, tu évoquais récemment le fait
que tu rêvais d’être
une meilleure “moi”
en disant que,
en fait, on ne voit que 10 % de ce que tu pourrais être.
Donc il y a 90 %
qu’on connaît pas encore.
Mais du coup, c’est quoi ?
- Alors, non,
je vois que 10 %
de ce que je pourrais être,
mais ça, ça vient
surtout en début d’année.
Je pense que ce truc un peu sociétal et collectif
qu’on a autour des bonnes résolutions autour de :
être une nouvelle personne,
nouvelle année,
nouvelle moi...
Et en fait, on est déjà
très bien comme on est.
Je pense qu’on n’a
pas besoin toujours
de devoir aller chercher plus, plus, plus, plus, plus.
Et moi, j’ai pris un peu
de temps aussi
pour m’en rendre compte que ce qui est déjà là,
c’est à savourer,
c’est à féliciter,
on en est déjà
arrivé jusque-là :
bravo à nous.
High five !
Pas besoin d’être constamment
dans cette recherche de...
tout recommencer
à zéro à chaque année.
Je pense que,
aujourd’hui...
Alors, moi, j’ai 25 ans,
vous, je ne sais pas
quel âge vous avez,
mais tu vois, tu calcules
le nombre de leçons
que tu as prises en 25 ans,
tu calcules le nombre de choses que tu as pu vivre,
bah ça, c’est des leçons qui valent quelque chose
et qui n’ont pas besoin d’être toutes balayées
pour
recommencer à zéro
parce qu’on est
le premier janvier.
- C’est des leçons de vie, quelque part.
- C’est complètement
des leçons de vie.
Tu collectionnes les leçons de vie,
les moments de vie,
les choses
que t’as apprises.
Et puis après, tu essayes de voir, de te dire :
OK, cette dernière année,
qu’est-ce qui m’a réellement rendu
heureux ou heureuse ?
Comment je peux
faire pour améliorer
mon quotidien
et faire en sorte de vivre
le plus possible de ces moments heureux ?
- Il y a des leçons de vie,
mais il y a aussi
des moments
plus compliqués.
Tu le disais tout à l’heure,
il y a eu
des hauts et des bas,
il y a ce que tu as vécu aussi en août 2022,
quand tu fais
une vidéo qui dénonce
le harcèlement
que tu subis,
et que tes proches subissent,
tes parents,
ta grand-mère en Algérie,
ça a été quoi
la goutte d’eau
qui t’a poussée à poster notamment cette vidéo,
ce truc qui te dit :
bon, là, c’est trop.
Parce qu’on imagine
qu’il y avait sûrement
une succession d’événements.
À quel moment tu te dis : bon, là, il faut vraiment
que j’en parle,
que je le partage.
Est-ce que tu peux un peu nous raconter tout ça ?
- Oui ! Alors...
En fait, j’en ai déjà
pas mal parlé,
de tout ce harcèlement,
et des fois ça me...
En fait, des fois,
je me dis,
tu comprends pourquoi
il y a des gens
qui n’en parlent pas,
parce qu’après t’es
un peu catégorisée
comme la meuf qui
s’est fait harceler
et j’ai envie de dire :
non mais je vous jure,
j’ai fait d’autres choses que de me faire harceler !
Mais c’est vrai que
c’est un sujet qui reste
quand même hyper important et sur lequel
je suis
assez heureuse
d’en avoir parlé,
d’avoir mis de
la lumière sur ça
parce que je sais pas
à quoi ressemblerait
aujourd’hui le contenu si
je continuais de mentir
et de faire semblant
que ça ne m’a pas
du tout affectée,
de faire semblant
que tout est OK
et que c’est normal
d’aller chez des gens
pour les insulter,
d’aller retrouver
des membres de
leur famille en Algérie
pour pouvoir leur dire que leur petite-fille est une...
insérez tous les gros mots que vous voulez,
et en fait, je me sentais obligée de le faire
parce que, justement,
on arrivait à la période
des vlogs d’août.
On est fin juillet
et je me dis :
mais je ne peux pas commencer demain
à faire une vidéo par jour.
Une vidéo par jour, tu peux pas mentir, tu peux pas...
Tu peux pas mettre une...
Enfin, je suis pas une bonne actrice, tu vois,
donc tu peux pas mettre un rôle pendant 31 jours
dans une situation où tu filmes toute la journée.
Tu montes, tu vlogues,
tu filmes, tu montes,
et en fait, tu ne peux
pas mentir sur ça.
Et je pense que si j’avais pas mis le holà sur tout ça,
et je pense que
si je n’avais pas dit
ce que je ressentais
depuis ces sept
derniers mois,
je n’aurais pas réussi
à faire les vlogs,
donc c’était soit
on fait les vlogs
et on reprend
les bonnes bases,
et je vous dis un peu d’aller vous faire foutre aussi
à tous ceux qui m’ont fortement minée
et qui aussi vraiment…
C’est pas que moi,
c’est vraiment
toutes les nanas
sur Internet,
et les mecs aussi,
en fait, c’est...
Ce qui est triste, c’est
que quand je poste
cette vidéo, donc j’ai
un énorme soutien
qui est fou,
mais ce qui m’a peinée, c’est le nombre
de créatrices de contenu
qui m’ont dit : mais
merci de mettre
des mots sur ça,
parce que c’est
des choses que je ressens
et que je vis.
Et en fait, on ne sait
pas comment en parler,
on ne sait pas
comment aborder le sujet.
C’est un sujet
qui est tellement chelou
et qui est trop bizarre.
Quand je le raconte
à des gens, ils me disent :
“J’ai pas compris pourquoi des gens ont jeté
des œufs sur la porte
de ta mère.
Ah, parce que t’as fait
un restaurant vegan ?
J’ai pas compris
du coup le...”
“Je sais, moi non plus.”
Et comme ça manque vraiment de rationalité,
mettre des mots
sur quelque chose
qui est tellement
peu rationnel,
c’est assez compliqué.
- Ça te montait dans
le cœur, dans l’esprit,
j’imagine, au quotidien,
il y avait cette envie
de le partager,
peut-être aussi pour
que ça change ?
- Je pense que c’était
surtout de la self-défense.
Je pense que j’étais arrivée au moment
où si je le fais pas,
je crois pas que
ce soit pour ceux
qui m’ont harcelée que
j’ai fait cette vidéo.
Au contraire, c’était
pour remercier
ceux qui étaient là et je l’ai faite aussi pour oim.
Mais bon.
- Récemment, il y a pas mal de streameuses
qui ont pris la parole, notamment sur Twitch,
pour évoquer,
pour dénoncer
le harcèlement, les commentaires sexistes
qu’elles subissent.
Quel rôle
toi, tu peux aussi jouer pour lutter contre ça ?
On a vu, notamment,
il y a certaines initiatives
qui ont été mises en place sur Twitch
pour modérer
les commentaires.
Voilà, comment faire
pour que ça change,
et avec la parole, la voix
que tu peux porter aujourd’hui ?
Je pense que les gens devraient tout simplement
arrêter d’être
des connards.
Il n’y a pas
de solution pour dire
à une personne d’Internet d’arrêter d’écrire
des messages désobligeants
parce qu’une femme est passée sur un écran,
tu vois.
En fait, cette phrase est quand même folle
de se dire :
des nanas sur Twitch
se font harceler
parce que ce sont
des nanas.
On va pas leur parler
de leur jeu,
on va pas leur parler
de leur live,
de leur éloquence,
de leurs idées,
de leurs valeurs,
on va leur parler
de leur physique,
on va leur parler du choix de leur tenue.
Et, non, c’est...
Comment tu veux mettre une règle sur un truc
qui est aussi con, juste :
arrêtez d’être chiants
et, pardon
pour les gros mots,
mais arrêtez
d’être désobligeants.
- C’est une question d’éducation aussi
quelque part.
- Je pense que c’est une question d’éducation,
pas forcément, parce que tu peux avoir reçu
une très,
très bonne éducation,
mais l’anonymat d’Internet peut te faire oublier
le temps d’un instant
tout ce que le système,
tes parents,
tes proches ont pu te...
Je pense que l’anonymat d’Internet
crée des choses
très, très positives,
permet d’ouvrir
la conversation
sur énormément de sujets
qui ne sont pas abordés dans d’autres médias
plus traditionnels.
Et justement, sous couvert d’anonymat,
tu peux te livrer plus, tu peux raconter des choses
que tu arriverais pas
à faire avec ton nom,
ton prénom,
ta tête affichée.
Mais il y a aussi
cette partie
beaucoup plus négative où tu peux aussi
te permettre d’avoir
des commentaires
misogynes, racistes, homophobes
et toutes les autres merdes qui s’ensuivent.
- Oui, c’est un débat
même politique,
depuis des années,
c’est la levée de l’anonymat sur Internet.
- Je ne sais pas
si c’est vraiment...
lever l’anonymat, hein.
- Parce que d’un côté, c’est vrai que ça permet
aussi à des gens
de s’exprimer,
de pouvoir dire...
- Mais après, évidemment,
il y a une responsabilité
de la part des plateformes,
de la part des
créateurs de contenu.
Nous, on ne
peut pas juste prendre
tous les aspects
positifs sans se dire
“oui, tu vas quand même
avoir des
aspects négatifs”,
sinon, tu vis dans un monde de bisounours
et ce n’est pas réel.
Mais je pense
que les plateformes,
du moins j’ai l’impression, essayent un petit peu
de faire
avancer les choses
en filtrant des mots,
en mettant des
contrôles parentaux...
En fait, je pense
surtout aux plus jeunes.
Tu vois, moi,
j’ai 25 ans, aujourd’hui,
un mec qui
m’envoie sa teub...
je suis en mode :
bon, c’est pas la première
que je reçois...
Ce qui est horrible
à dire en plus, mais....
Mais t’imagines
que si une petite fille
ou un petit garçon
qui va recevoir ça,
qui a treize ans, qui commence à peine
ou quoi que ce soit,
je trouve que ça,
c’est hard, tu vois.
Donc c’est
la responsabilité
des plateformes.
- Est-ce qu’elle est suffisamment respectée,
cette responsabilité
des plateformes ?
Quand on voit par exemple sur Twitch
que c’est des streamers qui sont obligés
de prendre eux-mêmes l’idée de créer une liste
pour censurer des mots pour faire en sorte
de protéger
la communauté…
- Non, mais je pense
qu’on reste encore
sur des métiers...
Enfin, on dit
“nouveaux métiers”
alors que ça fait
15 ans que c’est là, mais...
je pense que l’évolution était très, très, très grosse
et je pense que
tout le monde est arrivé
dans ce milieu en étant
un peu très optimiste...
À la base, les réseaux, c’était vraiment ça, quoi,
c’était l’activité extrascolaire
de tout le monde
et c’était que fun,
positif et arc-en-ciel.
Et maintenant,
je pense que c’est
beaucoup plus sombre.
Donc il y a la responsabilité
des plateformes,
il y a la responsabilité des créateurs de contenu.
Parce que je pense qu’aujourd’hui,
on a un tel accès
à nos stats, on a un tel…
Je sais qui sont
les gens qui me suivent,
je vois la tranche d’âge.
Donc moi, aujourd’hui, c’est majoritairement
des personnes
de mon âge,
mais je vois
qu’il y a encore une dose
de 13/17 ans, même si elle est minime dans les stats,
tu te dis : là, il y a
des enfants de 13 à 17 ans.
C’est pour ça que j’essaie de plus trop dire
de gros mots,
j’ai encore du mal,
mais tu te dis :
en fait, je peux pas...
Qu’est-ce que
ces jeunes-là,
t’as envie
de leur raconter ?
Sans rentrer
dans le jeunisme
et de faire un faux contenu en mode Gulli,
pour garder
ces jeunes-là,
mais comment tu peux
les accompagner
et comment tu peux leur proposer les valeurs
qui te touchent ?
- Et toi, tu arrives
vraiment à te protéger
par rapport à ça ?
Parce que j’imagine,
tu le dis justement,
tu dois sûrement regarder les commentaires,
les messages privés,
je regarde souvent,
je vois que c’est 99 % rempli de bons trucs,
mais des fois,
c’est plus compliqué.
Comment on fait ?
- Tu sais quoi ?
J’ai l’impression que
ça y est, j’ai passé le cap
et j’ai fait la paix avec le fait
que tu ne puisses pas plaire à tout le monde.
J’ai fait la paix avec
le fait que ton contenu
plaira pas à tout le monde.
Et puis j’ai fait la paix
aussi que... je pense
que beaucoup de personnes vont projeter
leurs insécurités sur toi, vont projeter des choses
négatives qui peuvent
leur arriver de leur côté.
Ils vont le projeter sur toi.
Et quand je dis toi,
je parle pas que de moi,
je parle sur Internet
en général, je pense que...
Hop là...
En fait, je me suis rendu compte que j’étais
la plus heureuse quand j’étais dans ma petite bulle
et que je cherchais plus
à plaire à des gens
dont le pseudo n’est même pas un réel mot.
- Ouais, parce que très souvent, ceux qui font ça,
c’est cachés derrière des pseudos... user95212...
- Ouais, derrière des photos de profil
et derrière des noms
qui ne sont pas les leurs.
- Donc, t’as réussi à prendre cette distance
aujourd’hui ?
- Ben, elle est nécessaire.
Sinon quoi ? Je vais
encore me morfondre
pendant un an, ça y est,
je l’ai fait l’année dernière,
j’ai pas du tout
apprécié l’exercice...
J’ai passé un
mauvais moment
quand j’ai vraiment
pris ça trop à cœur,
ça m’a rendue
moins productive,
moins heureuse,
ça a désolé mes proches,
je leur ai laissé beaucoup trop d’importance,
à ces commentaires négatifs.
Et du coup, l’humain est comme ça, il est con.
Pardon, il est bête.
Excusez-moi,
les 13/17 ans,
de dire encore
des gros mots.
L’humain a ce truc de :
on va se concentrer
sur le négatif
et c’est en même temps un peu sain de notre part,
ça veut dire que tu essayes de faire au mieux,
donc du coup,
tu comprends pas
que quelqu’un n’aime pas ce que tu essayes
de proposer au mieux,
mais c’est beaucoup, beaucoup plus sain,
croyez-moi,
d’aimer soi-même
ce que tu proposes
et de chercher son approbation à soi
plutôt que
celle des autres.
-Mais je vois bien l’idée,
parce que quand je regarde les mentions,
on peut avoir 99,9 %
de bons commentaires,
on a vu le 0,1 et ça, ça travaille, c’est un peu ça ?
- Ouais, mais c’est ça,
c’est comme...
Moi, je recevais
mon bulletin scolaire,
il y avait une prof,
ça m’avait...
Elle avait pas
aimé mon trimestre,
ça me foutait la haine.
J’étais en mode :
pourquoi ?
Et mes parents
me disaient :
“Non, mais c’est bien,
c’est pas grave
si t’es nulle en sport,
on le sait déjà, quoi !”
- Petite question pour toi sur un autre sujet, c’est :
comment on
protège sa vie privée,
même quand on se déplace dans la rue ?
Alors, je sais pas
si je devrais le dire,
mais je t’ai déjà
croisée plusieurs fois
en Vélib’ dans Paris.
- Ça m’étonne pas.
- C’est possible ?
- Ouais,
c’est fort probable.
- Mais du coup,
comment on se protège
par rapport à ça ?
Parce que c’est vrai
que t’as une popularité
qui monte
d’année en année,
et comment
on arrive à se dire,
surtout que
les réseaux sociaux
poussent
vraiment à dévoiler
beaucoup de choses,
à mettre une limite, quoi ?
- Écoute, je pense que,
au fil des années,
tu te rends compte
qu’il y a des choses
avec lesquelles tu es
à l’aise, d’autres moins,
je pense que
c’est propre à...
Chaque créateur
de contenu a sa limite.
Moi, j’ai trouvé
un certain confort
en racontant ma vérité
et en racontant des petites banalités du quotidien.
Ça me dérange pas
qu’on connaisse
pas mal d’aspects
de ma vie privée,
mais j’ai quand même
une petite ligne
en protégeant
les proches.
Moi, ça me dérange pas, tu vois,
mais c’est mon choix.
Tu veux pas
l’imposer à tes proches
qui eux n’ont absolument...
qui ne sont pas
dans ce corps de métier,
dans ce game-là, tu vois,
et qui prennent pas forcément de plaisir.
Donc du coup,
ça va plus être
protéger des proches,
protéger ceux
qui ne souhaitent pas
être exposés.
Parce qu’aujourd’hui,
si tu te fais un peu...
Si on te voit dans des vidéos, des stories,
peut-être qu’on va te reconnaître dans la rue,
même si je ne
suis plus avec toi
et qu’on n’est pas en train de tourner un vlog,
et tu peux...
C’est un exercice quand même assez particulier
d’être dans
sa petite balade
et que quelqu’un t’arrête pour faire une photo
ou quoi que ce soit.
Par exemple, je sais,
moi, que mon petit frère,
il est moins
à l’aise avec ça.
Il me dit : “J’aime bien,
mais je sais pas faire.”
Et je sens que je
crée une sorte de gêne
quand on me demande une photo, il est en mode :
il sait pas quoi
faire de ses bras,
comment faire
pour la photo, et tout,
et lui, ça lui plaît
pas de ouf !
Donc du coup, il y a des choses qu’on protège.
En fait, je pense qu’il ne faut pas se mettre
la pression de
vouloir en montrer plus
si t’es pas à l’aise
avec ce que tu montres.
Moi, je suis plein de créateurs de contenu
où je m’en fous de savoir
comment c’est décoré chez eux. Je m’en tape.
J’aime le contenu
qu’ils me proposent
et j’ai pas envie
d’en savoir plus.
Je pense que ma communauté a compris
les choses que je mettais pas forcément en avant
et le respecte.
On est bien avec ce que
je montre déjà, tu vois.
- Comment tu gères ça, par exemple, je sais pas,
si on crie
ton nom dans la rue,
que tu vois des gens
qui vont te suivre
sur des dizaines de mètres, voire plus ?
J’imagine que ça doit arriver parfois.
Comment
on gère ça un peu
quand on a des moments de vie privée ?
- Franchement,
je le gère plutôt bien,
parce que j’ai
la chance, vraiment...
On dirait que je fais la...
Salut, ça va ?
Pardon !
- C’est la vie, il faut vivre !
- Non, mais c’est
quand même fou,
on est dans les bureaux de Brut un lundi matin.
- Il y a du monde.
- Je dois les embêter, là.
Ils vont tous
vous emmener
aux prud’hommes
à cause de cette interview.
- On a voulu que
tu viennes un lundi
parce qu’il y a du monde.
Si on l’avait fait
le vendredi,
ça aurait vraiment fait l’arnaque totale
et on n’aurait
pas grand monde.
C’est pour ça, on a voulu qu’il y ait du monde
qui travaille
sur les bureaux et tout
parce que sinon, voilà !
C’était compliqué.
- Du coup, je disais
sur ma communauté,
vraiment très, très, très cool, très bienveillante,
et en même temps, ça te fait du bien aussi qu’on...
d’avoir une sorte d’interaction humaine
avec des gens
avec lesquels
tu ne converses
qu’en ligne.
Tu sais, c’est...
Moi, mon travail, ce que
je fais, c’est comme là,
je suis sur l’ordinateur
et je fais du montage,
ou alors je fais des mails, et donc ma journée,
c’est vraiment
constitué de :
être seule
derrière l’ordinateur.
Donc quand tu rencontres des gens
dans la vraie vie, en 3D,
que tu vois
comment ils parlent,
comment ils s’habillent, comment ils interagissent,
je trouve que c’est hyper, hyper enrichissant.
Et, alors,
parfois il y a des jours
où je suis plus
pressée que d’autres...
De toute façon,
tu m’as vue, sur mon Vélib’,
je trace.
- Ouais, ouais, moi, j’étais en trottinette électrique,
à ce moment-là,
je traçais aussi, mais...
- Est-ce que je t’ai tracé ?
- Ouais, à fond.
- Non, et surtout,
j’ai souvent le casque.
Ou alors juste,
des fois, un petit sourire,
un petit comme ça
et... parfois,
on a plus peur
pour ma sécurité,
parce que moi,
je suis une petite fille.
Tu vois,
ça m’arrive, des fois...
- Il peut y avoir des mouvements de foule,
des trucs comme ça.
- Ouais, moi, tu peux
me tuer facilement.
Je fais 1m60,
les gars, quoi.
- À la Fashion Week,
il faut y aller doucement,
parce que je sais qu’il y a
des centaines
de fans, quoi.
C’est dingue ça,
comme ambiance.
- Pour la Fashion Week,
ils m’ont mis des gardes du corps sur les défilés,
ou alors j’ai Marcus,
ou mon papa, ou Seb.
- C’est bien.
- Ouais.
- Et comment
on arrive à garder
des moments pour soi ?
- Ben...
- Il n’y en a pas ?
- Si, je... Je suis là, quoi.
- Et t’arrives...
- J’arrive à prendre
des rendez-vous
avec moi-même,
si c’est ça ta question.
J’arrive à prendre
des rendez-vous
avec moi-même, je me suis instauré des règles
que je me force à tenir.
Tous les matins, je me
fais une petite balade.
Avant de venir vous voir,
j’ai marché pendant
trois quarts d’heure.
En fait, je fait ça
tous les matins.
Au début,
je détestais le faire.
Pourquoi je me réveille pour aller marcher ?
Une demi-heure
de sommeil,
c’est un cadeau, quoi !
Quand le matin,
tu grattes une demi-heure,
c’est génial.
- Je calcule
avant de dormir :
il y a la conf à 9h30,
je calcule...
“Oh là !”
- Ouais, ben oui.
- C’est dur.
- La demi-heure
de sommeil,
elle est précieuse, elle est belle, c’est un cadeau.
Tu remercies le ciel
que tu te réveilles
et qu’il reste encore
une demi-heure à dormir.
Et les premières fois,
je me suis dit :
bon, allez, je vais aller marcher, quoi.
Pourquoi ? Je sais pas.
Dans quel but ?
Je ne sais pas.
Mais c’est parce
qu’à un moment,
j’étais très, très,
très, très miracle morning,
qui est une sorte
de conseils
de développement personnel,
de commencer sa journée pas avec le rush
de la journée mais avec un mini temps calme
que tu vas t’accorder à toi.
Et au début, je me réveillais à 4h du matin
pour m’accorder
du temps avec moi,
puis après, je me suis rendu compte que bon,
ça y est, on se connaît bien, moi et moi,
viens, on va dormir.
- Vous avez fait connaissance ?
- Voilà, j’ai bien fait connaissance
avec moi-même et...
Par contre, je rigole, mais ça m’a beaucoup aidée,
ça m’a rendue...
Juste : ne pas commencer sa journée sur du stress,
ça change le rythme
de toute ta journée.
Et ça peut
paraître très bête
que cette
demi-heure, vraiment,
régule mon
humeur sur la journée.
Donc voilà, je prends le temps avec moi-même.
Sinon, après, j’aime aussi,
quand je sens que j’ai eu beaucoup d’informations
dans la semaine et je sens que j’ai vu trop de gens
ou quoi que ce soit,
je dis à tout le monde,
de façon bienveillante, j’essaie, de dire :
je vous adore tous,
mais là,
je crois qu’il faut
que je passe l’après-midi
toute seule, moi-même, parce que sinon je vais...
J’ai pas
encore eu le temps
de mâcher
tout ce qui se passe.
J’ai pas eu le
temps de le digérer,
je suis encore
en train de le mâcher.
Donc si on peut juste me laisser une aprem seule
et tu vas
te balader, au ciné...
Le ciné seule,
c’est un vrai truc.
- C’est pas mal
parce qu’en fait,
quelque part,
au quotidien,
t’es dans une hyper sociabilisation,
où tu croises des centaines de personnes
potentiellement
qui veulent te parler,
entre le pro, les gens
qui te reconnaissent,
et il y a aussi des moments
où on se dit :
c’est super,
on adore les gens,
mais il faut aussi se retrouver avec soi-même.
- Ouais, exactement.
Je suis une introvertie
très sociale....
- Parce que quoi ? De base, t’étais plutôt timide,
plutôt...
T’arrivais pas trop à aller vers les gens ?
J’étais timide avec
mes propres idées.
Je pense
que l’âge adolescent,
c’est inévitable,
mais ça a un peu continué en grandissant,
j’étais timide
avec mes idées,
c’est-à-dire
que j’avais des rêves
que j’osais même pas,
moi, accepter
parce que je les trouvais trop fous.
Et du coup, c’est vrai que, au début,
j’étais timide
avec moi-même.
Et quand t’as du mal
à assumer qui tu es,
l’assumer
devant les autres,
c’est encore plus compliqué.
Mais après...
En fait, une fois l’adolescence passée,
je parle de l’adolescence comme si j’avais 50 ans,
mais,
une fois
le collège passé, je crois,
tu fais un peu la paix
avec ton corps,
avec tes complexes.
Après, il y en a plus
ou moins qui restent,
mais petit à petit,
tu te rends compte que chacun est dans son côté,
chacun est
dans son monde,
et en réalité,
si tu fais un truc de ouf,
que toi,
t’as trouvé un truc de ouf,
les gens, ils vont pas
s’en rendre compte,
donc tu peux
aller gambader,
tu peux aller courir,
tu peux avoir
des grands rêves,
tu peux...
aller seule au ciné,
personne
va mal te regarder,
tu peux aller manger seule au restaurant.
Les gens sont concentrés sur eux-mêmes, tu vois.
Pas en mode
c’est des gros connards,
mais on est
tous concentrés
dans notre
petit train de vie,
tu vois, on est déjà préoccupés par nos...
- Dans notre petite bulle,
et tout.
Ouais, on est préoccupés par nos angoisses
et nos problèmes.
On se concentre pas
sur ceux des autres.
- Ça ressemble à quoi,
une journée
de Léna Situations ?
Là, tu nous as parlé de ta petite balade, mais après,
une journée type,
parce que
j’imagine que
tu vas me dire aussi
qu’il n’y a aucune journée qui se ressemble,
mais il y a peut-être des fois des petits moments...
- Écoute, la blague
qu’on fait avec mes potes,
c’est que tu prends
deux activités
qui n’ont
rien à voir ensemble,
tu les mets les
unes après les autres
et c’est une journée
de youtubeuse, quoi !
- Un autre sujet aussi
que je trouvais important,
c’est celui de la santé mentale, justement.
Comment on prend soin
de sa propre
santé mentale
quand on est justement
au quotidien observée,
critiquée, commentée tous les jours ?
- Tu sais, je pense
que la vraie question,
c’est comment
prendre soin
de sa santé mentale
tout court.
Parce que c’est : chacun, individuellement,
on a nos angoisses,
nos problèmes,
les petits dos d’âne
dans ta journée
et c’est pas propre aux créateurs de contenu,
au contraire,
nous, on est
dans des situations
qui sont très privilégiées.
Je te le rappelle,
je travaille
et j’ai transformé
ma passion en un travail.
C’est pas des
journées de travail,
c’est des journées de kiff.
Alors évidemment,
il y a des moments
qui sont plus traditionnels et relous que d’autres.
Quand je me retrouve
à faire les vraies...
les vraies tâches
d’une jeune entreprise,
mais c’est un privilège immense, donc moi,
ma santé mentale,
elle se...
Des problèmes de qualité, j’ai envie de te dire.
Trop de gens
regardent mes vidéos ?
Ben d’un côté, j’ai tout fait
pour que les gens regardent mes vidéos
et je continue de le faire
pour que les gens prennent du plaisir
à regarder mon contenu.
Donc je peux pas
me plaindre
maintenant d’avoir des yeux scrutés sur moi
alors que j’ai tout fait pour.
Donc ça, c’est...
Mets le dessous, moi, j’en parlerai à ma thérapeute.
Mais par contre,
la santé mentale,
d’un point de vue général,
moi, la chose
sur laquelle je pense
qu’il faut mettre
vraiment de la lumière,
c’est toute
cette génération
qui vient de finir
les cours en Covid.
Enfin, il y en a qui ont
passé leur bac à distance,
il y en a qui ont fait
les deux ans à la maison
en télétravail de l’école.
Télétravail, au moins, tu sais, à la fin de la journée,
t’as gagné
de l’argent, tu vois.
Télétravail
de l’école, c’est...
Moi, l’école, j’ai tenu
parce qu’il y a les amis,
parce qu’il y a l’ambiance,
parce qu’il y a les moments magiques
et magnétiques
avec les copains
que tu te fais
au lycée et au collège.
Donc, pour moi, les gens
qu’il faut vraiment applaudir, déjà,
c’est toute la génération
après nous
qui vient de se taper ça,
cette génération qui est moins mise en lumière
qu’une influenceuse
qui fait juste
des vidéos sur YouTube,
et la santé mentale,
ce que j’adore, c’est que...
enfin, ce que j’adore...
j’adore pas
la santé mentale...
la phrase
trop mal tournée.
La santé mentale,
je trouve que ce qui est vraiment très positif
en ce moment,
c’est que le tabou
s’enlève petit à petit.
Déjà, le mot devient
un mot du quotidien.
Genre, c’est devenu stylé de dire santé mentale,
genre c’est devenu
un sujet d’actualité
alors que c’est présent
depuis
absolument toujours.
Je pense que vraiment,
si les gens du Moyen Âge
nous parlaient
de leur santé mentale,
il faudrait vraiment
des thérapeutes de ouf
parce que ce qu’ils ont mangé, eux, c’est chaud.
- Ça va être compliqué.
- Ça va être compliqué.
Mais le sujet s’ouvre,
le tabou s’enlève
et je pense que
plus on va en parler,
plus on va vraiment déculpabiliser les gens
de ressentir des choses,
plus les gens qui
ont vraiment besoin
d’être écoutés ou
juste même de parler,
même si personne
ne les écoute
et que eux s’écoutent eux-mêmes,
c’est gagné.
- C’est vrai qu’avant,
il y avait un côté tabou.
Ça pouvait même être vu comme une faiblesse,
quelque part. De se dire...
- Mais bien sûr !
Mais attends...
Je suis partie
voir le spectacle
de Roman Frayssinet,
son dernier one-man-show
qui est génial,
je vous le recommande.
Et dans son one-man-show,
il fait une vanne,
toujours très pertinente, hein, Roman,
il fait une vanne
sur dire que pleurer, c’est...
c’est la honte
et qu’un homme
qui pleure, c’est la honte.
Et il compare, en fait :
pleurer, c’est des émotions que tu extériorises,
comme chier, littéralement,
et que tu vas pas dire
à quelqu’un
“la honte, tu chies”, quoi.
Et donc lui, il comparait. Bon, c’est très...
C’est du Roman, tu vois,
mais il compare les larmes à cette sortie d’émotions,
cette sortie d’expression, ça a besoin de sortir,
tu vois. Et donc, du coup,
il encourageait
toute la salle à pleurer,
à accepter de pleurer,
que même un homme
qui pleure,
c’est pas la honte,
contrairement à ce
que beaucoup de gens
peuvent vous faire penser.
- Et il y a un besoin,
pour toi, justement,
d’extérioriser tout ça,
de partager ça
avec ta communauté ?
C’est vrai qu’aujourd’hui, voilà, quand à un moment,
on parlait de l’anxiété
que tu peux vivre
en ce début d’année,
c’est important d’en parler,
de partager avec
les gens que tu aimes
et en même temps les gens qui te suivent aussi ?
- Tu sais quoi ? Je pense que c’est important
d’en parler parce que moi,
ça m’a fait du bien de me connecter sur YouTube
et de voir qu’il y avait
des cours de méditation guidée gratuits,
libres d’accès,
qu’il y avait
des nanas et des mecs
qui parlaient
de leur anxiété.
Donc du coup, j’arrive
à mettre des mots
sur ce que je ressentais.
Mais alors,
j’étais encore
en train d’intérioriser
beaucoup de choses,
et en fait,
ce côté un peu
de “t’es pas tout seul”
quand tu fais de l’anxiété,
quand ta tête
vraiment t’isole
du monde autour de toi, c’est une grande aide.
C’est un peu
comme un câlin.
Du coup, moi,
je le vis comme ça.
- Toi, ça te fait du bien.
- Ça me fait
du bien d’entendre
des gens en parler
et ça me fait du bien
d’en parler et de voir
que t’es pas
le seul à vivre ça.
- Et puis je vois aussi,
ce que tu disais
tout à l’heure,
c’est de relativiser
parce que tu te dis :
il y a ce que je vis
dans mon quotidien,
mais qui est peut-être
un quotidien privilégié.
Et en même temps,
tu parlais des étudiants
avec ce qu’ils ont vécu pendant le Covid.
On a vu aussi les distributions alimentaires
où il y a eu beaucoup plus de monde qu’auparavant.
C’est toujours
d’essayer de relativiser
par rapport
à des situations
plus compliquées.
- Évidemment. Tu dis :
“peut-être
un quotidien privilégié”,
non, c’est clairement ça.
Pour moi,
à partir du moment
où tu travailles
avec ta passion,
on ne peut plus
se plaindre.
Tu peux avoir
des moments down,
mais relativise.
- Je connais ça aussi avec le journalisme, c’est pareil,
c’est aussi métier passion en mode : bon bah voilà,
on va sur le terrain,
des fois c’est dur,
des fois c’est compliqué,
mais on ne compte
pas ses heures, quoi.
- Non,
parce que c’est
ce qui t’anime,
c’est ce qui t’habite
et c’est ta lumière en toi.
Et vraiment, je souhaite
à toutes les personnes
qui nous écoutent,
si vous avez cette lumière en vous, vraiment,
mais je vous le souhaite
et vous méritez
de pouvoir ne faire
que ça de vos journées.
- Alors moi, perso,
je ne suis pas
très fan du montage,
c’est un peu la partie
où j’ai un peu plus de mal.
- C’est chronophage,
je comprends.
- Voilà, je préfère être
sur le terrain, tourner.
Toi, de ton côté,
c’est quoi ?
Le montage, ça va ?
Les tournages...
C’est quoi le truc un petit peu plus compliqué,
la petite tâche où tu te dis :
“bon, ben ça,
j’ai un peu de mal”.
- La partie
que j’aime le moins,
c’est de faire
les miniatures.
Les miniatures, tu sais, c’est la petite vignette
que tu vois quand
tu cliques sur YouTube,
et je suis mauvaise,
je suis mauvaise.
- J’ai les mêmes à faire
sur TikTok ici, à Brut,
et des fois, je me dis :
“je sais pas pourquoi
je fais ça”.
- Non, non, moi,
dès que je dois
ouvrir Photoshop
pour faire une miniature,
j’ai l’impression
que je ne sais plus
utiliser l’interface, quoi.
- Et t’as encore le temps
de faire tes montages toi-même ?
Après, je suis
moins régulière
que ce que
je faisais avant,
parce que justement,
je préfère aujourd’hui avoir plus de qualité
que de quantité,
alors que les réseaux nous poussent vraiment
à poster le plus possible.
Et en fait, je me suis rendu compte que moi,
j’avais trouvé ma joie
en étant fière
de ce que je poste.
Donc, même si c’est...
même si j’aurais pu faire trois montages pas ouf,
je préfère en faire un dont je suis fière et de me dire :
“OK, bon, ben, c’était
la bonne vidéo à poster”.
- En parlant de fierté,
il y a quelque chose
que j’ai remarqué,
tu me diras
si je me trompe,
mais on voit que tu réutilises de plus en plus
ton nom de famille
dans tes publications.
- Ça, écoute, je m’en suis pas rendu compte,
je sais que Yann m’avait posé la même question.
- Alors, j’avoue
que je n’ai pas fait
une enquête
approfondie de compter
combien il y a eu
de Situations...
- Est-ce que c’est l’heure de la pause dej
et c’est pour ça que
tout le monde se lève ?
- Ouais, je pense
qu’ils ont faim.
C’est magique.
Ouais, c’est l’heure
de manger, je pense.
- D’un coup, t’as senti
qu’il y avait l’énergie
de “j’ai la dalle”
dans la pièce, tu sens !
- En fait, tout le monde bosse assidûment,
et dès qu’il y en a un qui
se lève, hop, c’est parti,
tout le monde y va.
- Mais qui est le plus brave pour se lever en premier
et dire “on va manger” ?
- Ça peut être moi
parce que je prends jamais de petit déjeuner,
donc voilà, du coup...
- Pas bien.
- Je suis un peu en retard...
- Mais je fais pareil.
- Voilà !
Mais du coup, c’est vrai qu’on avait ce sentiment-là,
est-ce que c’est vrai, déjà,
est-ce qu’il y a eu
un déclic quelque part ?
- Écoute, je pense
que le déclic,
vous l’avez eu
un peu à retardement.
Mon nom, sur Insta,
ça a toujours été
Léna Mahfouf.
Je me suis pas cachée
de mon nom de famille.
Moi, je l’avais fait vraiment
pour des raisons beaucoup plus geekos,
parce qu’en fait, quand
tu tapais Léna Mahfouf
à l’époque, il n’y avait pas
beaucoup d’articles
ou de référencement
sur Google.
Donc si tu faisais
une faute de frappe,
moi, j’ai un h dans mon...
En vrai, mon nom de famille, c’est “Mahfouf”,
tu vois.
Et donc
si tu mets pas le h,
mon blog ne sortait pas,
et à l’époque,
j’étais vraiment juste
sur des problèmes
de référencement,
et donc “Situations”,
ça fonctionnait bien, comme ça, en plus,
comme mon blog
est en anglais
puisque je voulais surtout pas que mes camarades
à l’école le voient,
du coup, Léna Situations, “Situations”,
ça marchait
aussi en anglais.
Mais Insta,
ça a toujours été Mahfouf.
Je comprends la question,
parce qu’en effet, c’est
un nom de famille rebeu
et j’en suis fière...
Enfin, moi, c’est même pas une question.
C’est celui
que j’ai depuis toujours,
et même s’il ça m’a valu quelques moqueries
au collège et au lycée, puisque “ma fouffe”,
voilà, je vous laisse
faire le schéma
et imaginer
tous les surnoms
que j’ai pu avoir à l’école.
Mais non, ça ne m’a pas... J’en suis fière.
- J’ai une question :
À une époque, tu disais :
avant,
avec une réservation
au nom de Mahfouf,
il n’y avait pas de place,
avec Léna Situations,
il y en a...
- Attention ! C’est que
sur certains restaurants,
des restaurants prétentieux parisiens,
les PP :
prétentieux parisiens,
ça, c’est les pires.
- Et justement, comment
tu vis aujourd’hui,
peut-être
certaines remarques
que tu as pu subir
et des gens qui ont aussi peut-être des noms
justement arabes,
à consonance arabe,
le racisme que peuvent subir de jeunes filles,
hommes qui sont aussi des enfants d’immigrés
de première
ou deuxième génération ?
Parce que c’est vrai que
ce que t’as peut-être
pu vivre
dans certains restaurants,
certains le vivent pour
un entretien d’embauche,
pour un appartement...
- Tu sais, ce qui assez fou,
c’est que
toutes ces questions
qu’on me pose aujourd’hui,
quand on me les pose, je me dis : ah oui, en effet,
ça fait sens, mais en fait,
c’est un racisme
qui est tellement banalisé,
qui est de l’ordre
du quotidien,
que même
quand j’étais petite
et qu’on se moquait
de mes cheveux bouclés,
et que c’était amusant
de se moquer
de mes cheveux bouclés,
je voyais pas plus loin
que juste
les cheveux sont pas jolis,
je voyais pas tout ce que ça pouvait impliquer.
En fait, je ne comprenais pas non plus
l’importance et le message que passent
des cheveux bouclés assumés,
surtout que les miens
sont très présents
si on les lâche,
et je me rendais
pas compte
de tout
le message que c’est.
Par exemple, là,
au Festival de Cannes,
j’ai porté mes cheveux bouclés naturels.
C’est la première fois que je faisais un tapis rouge
avec mes cheveux naturels.
24 ans après une bataille contre des complexes
et contre justement
tous ces messages
qui me reviennent
d’un coup dans la tête
quand je vais lâcher
mes cheveux,
ceux qui viennent
de mes copines,
mes camarades
blanches à l’école.
Et en fait,
je me rendais pas compte du message politique
qu’on allait après me demander de porter
quand j’avais juste mis mes cheveux bouclés naturels
sur un tapis rouge.
Et en fait, j’ai senti une immense fierté
de réussir à le faire
et d’avoir combattu
tous ces complexes
qui ont été créés...
C’est pas que par
mes camarades,
mais c’est la société
en général,
c’est les diktats
de la beauté.
Surtout chez les femmes,
on nous met
une telle pression pour être jolies, fines,
intelligentes, présentes,
volontaires, dévouées,
ah, ça y est !
On est fatiguées, aussi.
Et donc du coup, se retrouver à porter ça,
c’était une certaine fierté, mais le message politique,
juste pour des cheveux bouclés,
ça m’a angoissée, tu vois.
Ça m’a angoissée
à quel point
il y a un tel manque
de représentation
qu’il suffit qu’une personne le fasse
et c’est un big deal.
Ça devrait pas
être un big deal.
Ça devrait pas être un message politique
de porter ses
cheveux naturels
quand toutes les meufs portent leurs cheveux
lisses naturels sur des tapis rouges, tu vois.
Pourquoi, quand c’est une nana aux cheveux bouclés
qui va le faire, ça va être
un message politique ?
Non, c’est mes cheveux.
Je suis née avec.
J’ai longtemps essayé
de les camoufler.
J’ai longtemps essayé de ressembler aux vôtres.
Maintenant que je les porte fièrement,
je comprends pas
le concept
du message
aussi politique.
Et d’un côté, je trouve qu’il est très important.
- Ça me fait penser
à une question
sur le rapport au corps.
Tu parlais souvent des 13/17 ans tout à l’heure,
t’as beaucoup de jeunes filles qui te suivent,
qui peuvent s’identifier
à toi
comme d’autres personnalités,
et voilà, souvent,
on va voir des photos
qui peuvent être retouchées,
où on présente le corps féminin de façon idéalisée.
Ça peut créer des complexes chez certaines
qui vont essayer de s’identifier à ces corps-là.
Comment, à ton échelle,
tu fais justement pour éviter ça, pour se dire aussi :
voilà, les 13/17 ans
qui me suivent,
où il y a un rapport qui est compliqué avec le corps,
donc soyez à l’aise, soyez à l’aise dans ce que vous êtes,
dans ce que vous faites.
Ce qui est rigolo,
c’est que quand tu me poses la question,
tu mets au féminin.
Tu dis “les filles
qui te suivent”
pour les complexes,
je pense que, justement,
on pense directement
aux femmes
parce que c’est majoritairement
sur les femmes qu’on injecte beaucoup
de diktats de beauté.
Je pense que
les garçons aussi
ont leur lot de complexes,
et c’est plus discret
chez vous,
mais si on parle des cheveux qui tombent,
je peux t’assurer
que tous les garçons
de la rédaction vont faire : “Quoi ?
Mes cheveux tombent ?”
Vous aussi, vous avez votre lot de...
Ça rigole derrière la cam !
- Je regarde
tous les deux, trois mois...
- Chacun regarde sa hairline comme ça.
- Je regarde tous les deux, trois mois
si je n’ai pas un début
de calvitie, perso.
- En fait, tu vois, c’est vraiment propre
à quasi tout le monde.
Et je pense que cette question doit plus se poser
sur les médias plus traditionnels,
ceux qui ont longtemps décidé volontairement
de n’afficher qu’un certain type de femme,
qu’un certain type
de garçon.
Quand les réseaux sociaux sont arrivés
en ouvrant la conversation justement sur ça,
je pense aujourd’hui que s’il n’y avait pas eu
les réseaux sociaux,
on n’aurait pas
aujourd’hui
la représentation
qui est en train
de changer.
On n’aurait pas sur les affiches publicitaires
dans le métro
que ce soit marqué
“photo retouchée”,
parce que c’est une nouvelle génération
qui a une sorte de ras-le-bol en disant :
en fait, on n’arrive plus
à suivre
tout ce que vous nous demandez d’être.
On n’arrive plus à suivre
ce camouflage
qu’on nous demande
de faire.
On a besoin que ça change parce que, en fait,
là, on arrive un peu
à un point
de non retour, tu vois.
- Pour toi, c’est important justement
de te présenter sur tes réseaux au naturel, aussi ?
C’est-à-dire :
ça peut être quand
tu te réveilles le matin.
Alors, à des moments, aussi, très apprêtée,
quand il y a des défilés, mais aussi des moments
plus simples de la vie quotidienne,
pour qu’on se dise :
ben voilà, la vie,
c’est aussi quand
on se réveille le matin,
je suis comme vous,
en soi.
- Je suis pire que vous, surtout.
Oui, non, c’est sûr.
Moi, je prends
un malin plaisir
pendant une
Fashion Week.
J’ai l’impression d’être
en soirée déguisée
toute la semaine,
et tu mets des extensions, tu mets du make-up
et tout, mais mon bonheur ne résulte pas sur ça.
Mon bonheur ne se résulte pas
sur mon apparence
et, pareil,
c’est ce qu’on disait avec les cheveux bouclés,
au début, quand j’ai commencé à faire
des vidéos YouTube
et que je me rendais pas forcément compte
du nombre de personnes qui regardaient les vidéos,
j’ai toujours été très à l’aise, peut-être parfois
un peu trop à l’aise, de me montrer démaquillée,
décoiffée, pyjamée
bien “joggossée”, tu vois...
Des fois, je faisais
des interviews
par la suite dans des médias type magazine, etc.,
ils me disaient :
“Vous êtes tellement
féministe de vous montrer démaquillée.”
Et t’es en mode “wow”.
En fait, ça prouve que
tout ce qu’on a consommé
est tellement retouché, édulcoré, mis en scène,
que d’avoir
une petite nana
de 18 ans qui
se montre démaquillée,
c’est un big move,
tu te dis :
“Non, vraiment,
c’est de l’ordre de...
C’est la base, quoi.”
Encore une fois,
ça devrait pas être
un message politique
d’avoir
une nana démaquillée
dans une vidéo YouTube.
Je vous en supplie.
Le combat ne se cache pas dans ça, quoi.
Donc...
Je comprends aujourd’hui
que ça se retrouve dans des questions d’interview,
mais crois-moi que
quand j’ai commencé
à me montrer démaquillée,
y avait pas du tout de choix politique derrière.
- Il y a pas de leçon,
de message...
- Non. Il y avait,
au contraire,
essayer d’être à l’aise
dans ses baskets,
essayer aussi
de se trouver jolie
sans filtre Insta.
Moi, là, ça fait deux ans que j’ai arrêté les filtres
dans les stories Instagram, tu sais.
Le filtre facile qui fait
la peau lisse.
- Ouais, je sais, je l’ai utilisé pas mal de fois aussi.
- Voilà, c’est celui qui tend un peu les sourcils
comme ça.
Et en fait, j’étais arrivée dans une sorte de...
de dysmorphie, où je me regardais dans le miroir
sans le filtre, genre :
il est où ?
Mes petites taches de rousseur, elles sont où ?
Et mon petit nez ?
Et j’en étais arrivée
à un moment où
il fallait que je fasse
une sorte de désintox,
parce que je sentais que
si tu te trouves jolie
qu’à travers le filtre Insta,
je savais que j’allais me perdre un petit peu.
- Sur un tout autre sujet,
toi, par le passé,
tu as évoqué,
la “honte de tes parents”.
Tu leur en voulais de ne pas gagner plus d’argent.
- Oui ?
- Pourquoi ?
C’était quoi,
ce sentiment, à l’époque ?
Parce que j’étais dans une école privée, à l’époque.
Attention,
je ne suis pas fière
de ce que je vais vous dire.
C’est assez vulnérable pour moi
de vous dire cette phrase.
Mais en effet,
quand je suis rentrée
dans une école privée,
donc, mes parents avaient mis leurs économies...
Un amour ultime
qu’un parent porte
pour son enfant,
et ils ont fait des sacrifices
pour que je puisse
faire mes études.
Et donc, du coup,
je me retrouve
dans cette école privée
avec des camarades
dont les parents n’avaient pas dû faire
les mêmes sacrifices
que mes parents
et pour qui
le prix de l’année,
c’était pas une grosse dépense, tu vois.
Et donc,
du coup, forcément,
je me suis retrouvée
dans une sorte de...
de choc, un peu, de classes sociales,
et j’avais l’impression
que comme mes copines
avaient des jolis sacs,
des jolies bagues,
des jolis lieux
de vacances,
elles allaient au Club Med et tout, je trouvais ça ouf,
et il y a eu le premier mois,
quand je suis arrivée
dans cette école,
où j’étais...
j’étais envieuse, en fait,
j’étais en mode :
mais pourquoi ?
Pourquoi, moi,
mes parents,
ils ont décidé
de justement
avoir
des métiers passion ?
Pourquoi mon père,
il a décidé d’être intermittent du spectacle ?
OK, il adore
faire du spectacle,
mais bon, il aurait pu être PDG d’une grosse boîte,
quoi.
Comme ça, j’aurais eu, comme mes copines,
des vacances
au Club Med.
Et au final,
tu te rends compte
de la bêtise,
tes yeux
s’adoucissent aussi
sur les vraies valeurs
de la vie
et les vrais cadeaux
de la vie.
Et moi, mes cadeaux,
c’était que justement,
mes parents,
en faisant
ces choix passion,
étaient présents.
Quand je rentrais
de l’école,
ma maman, elle était là,
ils m’aidaient
pour mes devoirs.
J’avais la richesse
qu’ils soient présents.
- La richesse de l’amour
au quotidien ?
- La richesse de l’amour,
la richesse des sacrifices qu’ils ont faits
pour que je puisse faire mes études,
et même quand j’en parle encore avec eux
aujourd’hui,
je leur dis : “Tout ça pour que je finisse youtubeuse,
quand même !”
Et ils disent :
“Non, aucun regret.
Ce chemin était le tien.”
Et pour rien au monde,
ils changeraient ce choix,
tu vois.
Donc non...
Et puis après,
en grandissant,
tu te rends compte
que vraiment, vraiment,
le bonheur ne se résulte pas dans le sac Chanel
que ma copine avait
eu pour ses 18 ans.
- Parce qu’aujourd’hui,
tu l’as et...
En fait, ce que je kiffe, maintenant,
c’est que
je me le suis offert,
moi, et je me le suis offert
avec de l’argent
que j’ai gagné
en faisant quelque chose que j’aimais faire,
et ça, c’est...
c’est une sorte de magie, quoi,
de pouvoir être fière
de ce que tu fais au travail,
mais surtout
d’être contente.
Tu sais,
c’est un vrai privilège.
Trouver du travail,
c’est horrible,
et être au quotidien
dans un job
dans lequel
t’es pas à l’aise,
dans lequel tu n’es pas apprécié à ta juste valeur,
être dans
un métier où, en fait,
t’es juste un pion
un peu remplaçable,
c’est une vraie
épreuve à traverser,
et c’est pour ça que, aujourd’hui, oui,
évidemment que moi,
je suis contente
d’avoir réussi à faire mon petit truc, mais je sais pas,
très reconnaissante,
en tout cas.
- Alors, sur ton parcours, justement,
tu disais que tu ne voulais pas servir d’exemple
à la théorie
de la méritocratie,
le “quand on veut,
on peut”,
mais pourtant, quand
on regarde ton parcours,
on voit que tu t’es donné énormément de mal,
t’as cumulé des petits jobs pour payer tes études,
il y a eu ton année
à New York...
Est-ce que tu représentes pas un petit peu
malgré tout ce symbole ?
- Tu sais quoi,
moi, j’ai un côté
très schizophrène sur ça, parce que j’ai ce truc où...
T’es forcément au courant de ton privilège,
déjà juste d’être né dans une famille aimante,
c’est ouf !
Moi, quand je grandissais,
je croyais que c’était la base pour tout le monde
et au final, avoir
des parents présents,
papa et maman heureux
et qui donnent de l’amour à leurs enfants,
ça, déjà,
ça te construit vraiment
beaucoup de choses
dans ta tête, quoi.
C’est que j’arrivais avec des idées, mes parents,
ils les écoutaient,
ils m’ont jamais dit :
“Tu devras faire
ce parcours-là
et c’est comme ça
et pas autrement.”
Donc ça :
privilège énorme.
Donc évidemment, tu pars avec un temps d’avance.
Je suis née en France, temps d’avance,
carte vitale,
temps d’avance.
Donc, du coup, évidemment
qu’il y a ce côté
temps d’avance, mais,
c’est pas
pour autant que...
J’ai aussi ce truc
de me dire :
si moi, j’ai réussi à sortir
de ce petit chemin
qui devait être beaucoup plus traditionnel
et classique pour créer
ce que je voulais faire,
j’ai l’impression
que si moi, j’ai réussi...
J’ai pas utilisé de la magie,
je n’ai pas utilisé
des contacts magiques,
de l’argent magique
tombé du ciel, non, j’avais juste vraiment très, très,
très envie de le faire,
et évidemment,
je me suis
donné les moyens
et il y a un moment où je travaillais beaucoup,
beaucoup, beaucoup
dans l’objectif de vivre
ce que je suis en train
de vivre aujourd’hui.
Mais j’ai encore
ce truc de me dire :
si moi, j’ai réussi à le faire,
je pense que c’est faisable parce que même moi,
je misais pas
sur moi à la base, tu vois.
- Ah ouais ? T’avais un manque de confiance ?
- Nan, mais je rêvais
d’aller au Met Gala
alors que j’étais...
j’étais là, quoi.
J’étais juste :
c’était le Met Pas Là.
J’étais...
Je grattais des invites...
Je rêvais, moi,
d’assister aux défilés,
les Fashion Weeks,
c’est quelque chose
vraiment qui m’a
toujours émerveillée.
Le milieu de la mode,
et je te parle pas
de faire du shopping,
je te parle de l’art,
de la mode, le vrai,
la haute couture, la création dans les ateliers,
c’est quelque chose qui m’a toujours fascinée,
animée
et j’ai toujours voulu
être une petite souris dans les ateliers pour pouvoir,
après, par la suite, partager ça avec des gens
qui, comme moi,
en rêvaient.
Et donc, du coup,
mes premières
Fashion Weeks,
j’allais devant les
défilés avec un rêve,
tout simplement,
et je suppliais les gens
d’avoir une petite
place pour entrer.
Et ça a marché,
et c’est comme ça
que j’ai fait
mes premiers défilés.
C’est comme ça
que j’ai rencontré
les premières personnes
qui avaient un
pied dans la mode.
Petit à petit,
j’ai essayé de montrer
qui j’étais et
ce que je voulais faire.
Donc évidemment
que tu pars d’un privilège,
ce que je te citais avant,
mais il y a quand même une certaine partie de :
il fallait y croire
vraiment, très, très fort
et se donner les moyens.
J’en perds ma voix.
- Il y a une petite
bouteille d’eau qui traîne...
Tu as ce truc aussi de dire :
en vrai,
je l’ai juste fait, quoi.
- Il y a aussi la question, toute à l’heure, justement,
tu parlais de la
Fashion Week,
des événements qui
sont assez prestigieux,
comment on arrive
à rester authentique
quand on est invitée, justement,
à des défilés de mode,
qu’on fait des partenariats avec des grandes marques,
qu’on gagne
aussi plus d’argent,
comment on arrive à garder les pieds sur terre ?
- Ben, si tes valeurs de base restent les mêmes.
Si tu vas à un défilé juste pour montrer que toi,
t’as été à un défilé, que c’est juste une part d’ego,
évidemment
que tu vas y perdre
beaucoup en authenticité.
Par contre, si t’y vas
dans le but de partager
ce que tu viens
de vivre, en te disant :
OK, ben moi,
j’ai eu la chance,
et peut-être qu’ils se sont trompés, mais en tout cas,
ils m’ont invitée,
j’ai eu la chance de rentrer dans ce milieu très fermé,
maintenant,
rentrez avec moi,
donc il y a un peu ce truc de, à travers la caméra,
même si j’arrive
pas à faire venir
3 millions de personnes sur un défilé, parce que...
- Ça fait du monde.
- Ça fait du monde,
mais par contre,
si à travers un vlog,
à travers des stories,
à travers des lives,
je peux faire vivre ne serait-ce qu’un petit bout
de ce que je
suis en train de vivre,
tu gardes
des bonnes bases.
- Il y a aussi la question vis-à-vis de ton entourage,
j’imagine, voilà,
on passe d’une étudiante
à quelqu’un de très connu.
Est-ce que tu as réussi à garder tes amis d’enfance ?
- J’ai surtout gardé
que eux,
parce qu’il ne faut pas s’entourer de yes men.
On appelle ça les
yes men dans ce milieu.
Il y a beaucoup de gens qui entourent
une personnalité,un artiste ou quoi que ce soit,
qui disent oui à tout.
“Oui, c’est super.
Han, mais c’est génial.
Oui, viens, on fait ça.”
Mais c’est parce que
c’est des gens
qui vivent aux dépens de...
si toi, tu vis, quoi.
C’est des gens qui gagnent de l’argent
si toi,
tu gagnes de l’argent.
T’es entourée
de yes men, tu vois.
Et le but,
c’est de complètement
se séparer de ça
et d’être entourée
de gens honnêtes,
et qui de plus honnêtes
que ceux
qui te connaissaient
avant que
des gens te suivent ?
- Ça veut dire que
quand on est en 2023,
qu’on s’appelle
Léna Situations,
se faire de nouveaux amis,
ça doit être
un peu compliqué ?
- Non, après, ça va, je suis pas non plus un monstre.
J’ai beaucoup de
place dans mon cercle.
- Non, mais c’est de se protéger, quelque part,
parce que c’est vrai qu’il y a aussi la notion des gens
qui peuvent profiter,
qui peuvent...
- Évidemment, mais bon...
En fait, il faudrait
que tu rencontres
Marcus et Solène,
mes deux meilleurs amis,
pour te dire...
même si on voulait
faire rentrer
quelqu’un d’autre,
il n’y a plus de place.
Déjà, on se parle
les uns sur les autres,
on se voit toute
la journée, tout le temps.
J’ai plus de place du tout.
- C’est ton
vrai cercle intime.
- Non mais en fait,
tu sais quoi ?
C’est ceux qui
étaient là avant
et ceux qui
seront là après.
C’est juste ça qu’il faut se dire, et c’est des gens,
quand j’ai une mauvaise idée, ils me disent :
“Non mais Léna, c’est vraiment de la merde.”
Et c’est ceux
qui vont te dire :
“Excuse-moi,
mais je comprends pas,
dans ta vidéo, t’as dit ça,
mais ça veut pas dire... articule, tu vois.”
C’est ceux qui
te veulent du bien
et c’est surtout
ceux qui s’en foutent
de ce que je fais
comme job.
- J’imagine que...
c’est ce que tu disais,
t’as plein de gens
qui vont dire oui à tout
parce qu’ils ont
envie de te faire plaisir,
ils osent pas
forcément te contredire.
Et heureusement
que t’as ces gens-là
qui sont à la base
et qui vont dire...
Le jour où
tu fais de la merde,
ils sont capables
de te le dire.
- N’oublie pas,
j’ai des parents rebeus,
donc la vérité sortira toujours de leur bouche
si un jour je me
laisse pousser des ailes.
- Il y a une question
qui est aussi importante,
on l’a vu cette année,
je sais pas comment
tu as suivi un peu
ce clash perpétuel entre Booba et Magali Berdah,
mais ça a posé la question, justement,
de tout ce qui est en lien avec les partenariats.
Comment, toi, tu fais
pour que ces partenariats soient éthiques ?
Pour que ce
que tu partages
avec ta communauté,
ça respecte, justement,
les valeurs que tu veux véhiculer au quotidien ?
- Bah déjà, il y a des règles,
il y a des lois
qui sont bien inscrites.
Et ces lois te demandent
de ne pas parler
de produits dangereux, frauduleux,
de dropshipping.
Alors, ça reste très flou,
ce que ça veut
réellement dire,
parce qu’on est
encore sur un métier
qui n’est pas
100 % structuré
d’un point de vue légal,
mais ça va vachement
se légiférer avec le temps.
Donc grosso modo,
ce que je fais,
c’est que je parle
de marques
que je consomme,
je parle de marques
que j’apprécie,
je parle de marques dont je suis à l’aise de parler.
Et j’essaye aussi
un petit peu
de diversifier
et de pas parler que...
Tu vois, par exemple,
je travaillais avec des maisons de mode
et de couture, donc
du coup, évidemment,
ça va pas être
les mêmes prix.
Et j’essaye un peu
juste de trouver
une bonne balance,
j’essaye de trouver un peu
avec quoi je suis
le plus à l’aise.
Mais en réalité,
j’ai mes petites règles.
Mais c’est vrai,
j’ai quelques
clients à l’année et...
- La question,
c’est de se dire
peut-être des entreprises qui respecteraient pas
des normes
écologiques ou...
- En fait, c’est
des règles de base de :
ce produit, est-ce que
tu le consommes
ou est-ce que tu es en train de mentir aux gens ?
C’est ça.
Mais tu vois, Booba,
ce qu’il est en train
de faire, c’est...
c’était
tellement nécessaire.
C’était tellement nécessaire
de bien marquer
une différence aussi
entre les gens
qui ont travaillé
pour avoir
leur communauté,
ceux sur lesquels
c’est le travail
de plusieurs années,
ceux qui vont sortir
juste d’un télécrochet...
Attention, je dis pas
que c’est pas du travail,
parce que je pense que c’est de sacrés tournages,
mais ceux qui vont
sortir d’un télécrochet
et qui d’un coup vont avoir une masse d’audience
qui va arriver, qui s’est pas construite sur des années,
donc, du coup, il y a peut-être moins, aussi,
ce rapport en se disant “c’est des vrais gens”,
parce que moi,
ça m’a pris du temps
à m’en rendre compte, peut-être que eux
ne s’en sont pas
encore rendu compte.
Du coup, ils se permettent de faire la promotion
de produits qui sont plus douteux que d’autres.
Mais je trouve
ça génial que Booba...
Je trouve ça même ouf qu’aujourd’hui,
cette conversation arrive
grâce à Booba, franchement.
La piraterie, quoi.
Donc bravo à lui d’avoir mis la lumière sur ça
et je pense que
l’État va commencer
vraiment aussi à prendre ça très au sérieux,
parce que
quand il y a des jeunes
qui se font arnaquer, quand ils se font
influencer pour
acheter des produits
qui sont dangereux,
mais tu sais, des vrais
produits dangereux,
je te parle pas
d’un vêtement,
je te parle de produits
qui vont te “faire maigrir”,
mais en fait qui vont juste te détruire l’estomac,
ces produits que tu vas t’appliquer sur la peau,
mais qui ont des compositions
complètement étranges. Enfin, c’est quand même...
Pour moi,
c’est de l’ordre de la base.
- L’initiative de Booba,
je rebondis dessus
parce que je te
vois enthousiaste,
c’était important
qu’il y ait quelqu’un
qui donne un coup de pied dans la fourmilière ?
- Oui, mais je pense que l’État, nous, on le voit,
essaie de plus en plus contrôler, légiférer
et c’est ce qu’il fallait.
C’est que là, pour l’instant, c’est ce qu’on disait,
c’était une activité extrascolaire
pour beaucoup, maintenant, ça devient
un vrai métier et il faut qu’on soit tous cadrés,
régulés sur ce job, comme tous les autres jobs.
- Alors, qui dit fin de l’interview dit aussi :
on a parlé de 2022, de l’anxiété de début 2023,
de tes rêves aussi,
et c’est quoi, un peu,
tes projets
pour cette année ?
Qu’est-ce qui
va se passer bientôt ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on va voir ?
Déjà, rester en vie,
ce serait bien.
Bon projet, je trouve.
Franchement,
si je peux continuer
à créer du contenu
et de divertir des gens,
je suis gagnante, peu importe la plateforme.
Récemment, je me suis lancée sur le podcast.
C’était, je pense, le format qui me manquait,
un format plus long
où tu peux rentrer
beaucoup
plus en profondeur
sur certains sujets.
Tu vois, on parle de l’anxiété, par exemple,
c’est des sujets, c’est difficile de les aborder
dans une story
de 15 secondes
ou sur une vidéo YouTube, où on essaye un peu
de ramener plus
de légèreté, de lumière.
Du coup, c’est vrai
que le podcast,
le fait déjà que
tu te retrouves seule
face à un micro, dans une position très vulnérable,
et si t’acceptes
de faire l’exercice,
tu le fais avec
une réelle envie
de créer une conversation.
Et donc le podcast Canapé 6 places,
c’était vraiment
quelque chose...
Quand j’ai fait le premier épisode, je me suis dit :
“Mais waouh, pourquoi
j’ai pas fait ça plus tôt ?
Pourquoi je me suis pas
mise à cet
exercice plus tôt ?”
Et puis ce qui est génial, c’est qu’aujourd’hui,
on essaye de mélanger des conversations solo
et des conversations
avec des invités.
J’ai eu le grand honneur de recevoir plein d’invités
géniaux, très talentueux, mais tous diversifiés.
Tu vois, c’est pas juste
une youtubeuse
qui va interviewer
des youtubeurs.
Vraiment, on sort
un peu de ce spectre
parce que le format
du podcast fait
qu’on a tous un petit peu envie de parler.
Tu sais, quand t’arrives
sur un plateau télé,
je sais pas si vous savez,
mais le temps de parole est chronométré,
t’as le droit à 4 minutes,
tu viens pour promouvoir un projet, donc du coup,
c’est assez
mode auto-pilote.
Alors que sur le podcast,
tu peux te permettre
de converser
comme là on le fait.
Je ne sais même pas si ça vous intéresse, mais...
- Mais si, c’est génial, justement, parce que,
ce qui est plaisant,
et moi, je le sais aussi
en tant que journaliste,
ça m’arrive, des fois,
on me dit : t’as 15 minutes pour faire une interview.
- Ouais, c’est dur.
- C’est frustrant,
t’es là, t’as ta feuille,
t’as même pas fait les deux tiers qu’on te dit
“bon, ben c’est fini”.
C’est dur.
- Et puis c’est
tout simplement
des bons moments
que je passe.
Et ce qu’on disait
tout à l’heure,
c’est qu’il y a des
choses qui ont changé
dans ma vie depuis
que je fais des vidéos,
j’ai rencontré beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup
de gens qui sont tellement intéressants et généreux...
Ça peut être des acteurs,
ça peut être
des chanteurs,
ça peut être des auteurs.
Et en fait,
ces conversations-là,
quand je les vis, je me dis :
c’est des choses
à ancrer dans le temps,
à partager, parce que...
quand je rencontre
une Géraldine Nakache
qui est maman et qui va
te donner des conseils
remplis de bienveillance, d’amour,
ou un Pierre Niney
qui va te raconter
comment il s’est complètement désinhibé
du regard des gens,
tu te dis
“mais ça,
c’est des choses qui, moi,
m’ont vraiment
touchée profondément,
qui m’ont marquée
et qui seront
des changements
dans ma vie”,
j’ai envie de le partager,
donc c’est comme ça qu’on a le podcast
aussi avec les invités.
- Petite question
qui revient souvent.
Alors, je vais pas te demander ton avis
sur la réforme
des retraites,
mais ça me fait rebondir avec une question.
C’est : tu la vois
à quel âge, la tienne ?
- Ma retraite ?
- Ouais.
- J’ai pas de juste milieu,
c’est soit l’année prochaine,
soit dans 75 ans.
- Ah ! 75 ans, carrément ?
- Ouais, moi,
je suis scorpion,
c’est tout ou rien.
- Ça fera plaisir à certains ! Travailler plus...
- Non, non.
Je peux comptabiliser
des heures en plus
pour vous si vous voulez.
- C’est pas mal.
- Vous voulez ?
J’en prends. Ça me dérange pas.
- On a parlé des
petits trucs compliqués,
mais j’imagine, si t’avais
un petit mot pour 2023,
pour tous ceux qui
te suivent au quotidien,
qui t’envoient
beaucoup d’amour aussi
tous les jours ?
- Ça va faire, je crois,
ma cinquième
année exposée,
je suis sûre que
vous en avez marre
de voir ma gueule,
moi aussi.
Mais si vous êtes resté
jusqu’à la fin
de cette vidéo,
c’est qu’on
partage un petit bout
de 2023 ensemble.
Merci de suivre
mes aventures,
merci de suivre
ce drôle de métier
et toutes les
réflexions qui vont avec.
Et je suis particulièrement reconnaissante.
Là, tu vois, cette année, t’as envie de commencer
en te disant :
c’est fou ce que je vis
et j’ai envie d’être digne de l’amour qu’on me donne
et de cette plateforme qu’on m’a donnée.
- Et qu’est-ce qu’on
peut te souhaiter ?
- Une sieste.